[Musique]
c'est devant ce cabanon aux portes
rouges que s'est achevée la cavale de
valentin marcotte le suspect s'est rendu
à une patrouille de militaires à gary
affaibli après quatre jours de traque
on sent que c'est quelqu'un qui avait
peur qu'ils ressentaient de la peur
vis-à-vis de certaines personnes du
village effet fait peur de voir ces
individus éventuellement s'en prendre à
lui et à sa famille qui l'avait conduit
à porter un gilet pare balles pour se
rendre à son travail depuis près de
trois ans et à se rendre aussi à son
travail avec une arme de poing sous ses
vêtements depuis aussi vite plusieurs
mois un immeuble de plus s'effondre à
gaza israël assure qu'il servait comme
centre de renseignement du hamas
ce qui est sûr c'est qu'il abritait deux
médias étrangers un américain l' agence
locale d'associatifs presse et des
locaux de la chaîne du qatar al jazira
heureusement nous avons pu évacuer à
temps mais le monde en sort à moins
aujourd'hui sur ce qui se passe à gaza à
cause de cette attaque
des manifestations de colère ont eu lieu
dans plusieurs villes de cisjordanie
hier à l'occasion du 63e anniversaire de
la nakba la catastrophe qu'a représenté
pour les palestiniens la création
d'israël
alors dès 14h30 sur le boulevard barbès
lorsqu'un premier groupe se forme les
forces de l'ordre russes de leurs canons
à eau pour disperser les manifestants à
londres aussi des milliers de personnes
se sont rassemblées mais cette fois ci
dans le calme aux centres de hyde park
un drapeau palestinien de plusieurs
mètres est porté par la foule quand les
manifestations sont autorisées elles se
passent bien pour ça on a déjà on peut
constater en province partout elles ont
été autorisées n'y a pas eu de
débordement n'y a pas eu d'incident et
j'ai envie de dire c'est exactement si
ce qui s'est passé en 2014 rarement on a
vu un dispositif policier de ce type qui
rappelle plus les états policiers qu'une
démocratie
donc évidemment que c'est une erreur tu
es de l'avoir fait mais c'est une erreur
politique c'est une volonté politique
qui ont en réalité de la part du mythe
de la terre de criminaliser l avance les
soutiens
aux palestiniens aux affrontements se
sont poursuivis également dans le ciel
vers minuit le hamas a lancé une
nouvelle salve de roquettes intercepté
ici au dessus de mode in dans le sud
d'israël par le dôme de fer le système
israélien de défense anti aérienne pour
faire reculer le cortège les forces de
l'ordre lancent des grenades
lacrymogènes et utilisé à nouveau leurs
canons à eau
il confie ce que même le drapeau
palestinien de ce manifestant vu le
dispositif policier qu'il y avait hier
pour une manifestation qui étaient
interdites toutes été mis en place pour
qu'il y ait des tensions avec les
manifestants et les manifestantes et
manifestations sans accrochage enfin en
belgique en tunisie ou en espagne loin
du tumulte des rues parisiennes
je veux pas tout mélanger deepak quand
on est sensible à la cause palestinienne
on est forcément en soutien du
terrorisme d'un islamisme radical faut
pas tout mélanger mais dans ces
manifestations et des éléments
perturbateurs violent peut-être qu'ils
ont des messages à caractère haineux
voire terroristes qui s'infiltrent
l'effondrement des gradins une synagogue
une porte d'aix près de jérusalem
les médias israéliens évoquent ce soir
deux morts et plus de 60 personnes
blessées
si lui c'est lepénisé sur bien des
sujets et l'autre elle c'est ma
chronique et elles sont d'accord tous
les deux pour venir vous dire la bouche
en coeur oui nous rembourserons la dette
a oui vous allez rembourser la dette
et comment s'il vous plaît c'est une
constante dans chacune de ses prises de
position on voit bien comment jean luc
mélenchon est celui qui rêve du désordre
maximum pour aspirer au pouvoir par des
voies que le suffrage universel ne lui a
jamais accordé